Texas police are expected to release new
information today about the
investigation into a double murder and a
possible international hunt for the
suspects James Butler the third and his
wife Michelle Butler were found in a
shallow grave on Padre Island in Texas
dozens gathered for a vigil in the
couple's New Hampshire hometown last
night meg Oliver is on North Padre
Island with more on this story meg this
was disturbing and very devastating to
the family members what else can you
tell us about this couple disturbing
indeed Gail good morning this is the
beach where James and Michelle Butler
were last seen the couple have been
traveling the u.s. and an RV since 2018
but in mid-october they abruptly went
silent and their trailer and RV
allegedly crossed the us-mexico border
without them more than a hundred people
gathered Sunday night for a vigil in
Rumney New Hampshire a small town where
James and Michelle Butler fell in love
and married in 2015 they did everything
together they loved each other deeply
Jabbar Van Loon is James's older sister
she says her brother and Michelle were
inseparable they were always together
and smiling and having fun and doing
what they loved James was a retired Navy
veteran in the couple had been on a
cross-country road trip and a used RV
trailer taking odd jobs along the way to
make ends meet Deborah says they were
likely headed to Florida next to sell
Christmas trees we knew something was
wrong because they never missed phone
calls
most recently the couple was staying in
their trailer on a beach on Padre Island
right outside of Corpus Christi
it's where police say their bodies were
found buried in the sand dunes on
October 27th several days after they
were first reported missing
but the Kleber County Sheriff's Office
says the truck and our V trailer that
couple was traveling in was nowhere to
be found investigators say both vehicles
were last seen on surveillance video
between October 20th and 21st crossing
the us-mexico border the driver was not
James or Michelle police haven't named a
possible suspect
it's not very often that we have a
mobile crime scene if the crime was
committed say in the trailer John
Matthews is a former Dallas police
officer he says US authorities will have
to work closely with Mexican authorities
to get answers they're gonna be looking
for bullet casings you're going to be
looking for any evidence they can tie
back to the suspect this is a horrific
crime and we certainly want to bring
those individuals into custody
the couple had five grown children and
one grandchild over the weekend it was
James Butler's birthday he would have
turned 49 years old investigators are
not saying how they died but they are
holding a press conference later this
morning Tony all right we'll be
listening in Meg thank you very much